what is the biological significance
of the visual
pathway amplification transduction
scheme
Beyond vision
doesn't have a broader import
and it certainly does
and what we did not expect when we
carried out these studies
is that it would be an example
of how a g protein works and so it has
an importance that extends Beyond vision
and one of the beautiful things about
nature
is that we see the recurrence of
mechanisms very often because of
homology because of common dissent
and sometimes because of analogy
but in this case
understanding Vision illuminates a vast
array of signal transduction processes I
would just say offhand that maybe a
third of all signaling processes are
mediated by g-protein pathways